it's Thanksgiving turkey stuffing mashed
potatoes but the one thing that is
always stood out is a bit of a
head-scratcher sweet potato casserole
we're pretty sure sweet potatoes and
marshmallows weren't at the original
Thanksgiving so what happened sweet
potatoes have been around forever and
marshmallows this sticky gooey mess
actually comes from a plant and has been
around since ancient Egypt a delicacy
only pharaohs could eat okay
fast-forward to the 20th century
marshmallows were a big deal expensive
and essentially the crystal of sweet
treats and not only that but they were
even handmade marshmallows became a
mainstay for highfalutin housewives see
back then housewives would have to make
whipped cream or even meringue by hand
but the marshmallows were a modern
time-saver the first recipe that paired
sweet potatoes and marshmallows appeared
in 1918 in a trade journal cleverly
named sweet potatoes and yams as
marshmallows grew in popularity and
began being mass-produced more and more
recipes began implementing them as an
everyday ingredient nowadays
marshmallows are generally reserved for
campfires and hot chocolate and this non
traditional traditional favorite whether
you like your sweet potatoes on a
marshmallow or plain Happy Thanksgiving